[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
paris schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen was im sport passiert
erfahren sie von von mir auch einen
schönen genommen blicken wir auf die
themen des tages
bundeswehr einsatz in mali auf der kippe
bericht über russische söldner im land
sorgen in berlin für unruhe
rede an die union ursula von der leyen
will die eu widerstandsfähiger machen
nicht nur gegen die pandemie
und traumstart in die champions league
der fc bayern schlägt einen schwachen fc
barcelona mit 3 zu 0 heute abend müssen
dortmund unten leipzig ran
und es verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer stellt den bundeswehr
einsatz in mali in frage der grund das
malische militärregime erwägt offenbar
den einsatz russischer söldner
frankreich hat deswegen auch schon mit
einem abzug seiner truppen bedroht am 2
internationalen einsätzen ist die
bundeswehr in mali beteiligt an einer eu
ausbildungsmission und an der un-mission
- mal mit insgesamt fast 1.000
soldatinnen und soldaten - mal soll vor
allem den durch islamistische rebellen
bedrohten norden malis stabilisieren die
meisten deutschen kräfte sind nach
stationiert über die drohung der
bundesverteidigungsminister in sie von
dort abzuziehen andrea maurer in mali
befindet sich die bundeswehr in ihrem
gefährlichen auslandseinsatz das die
malische militär runter mit russischen
söldnertruppen kooperieren könnte dass
die französische regierung deshalb heute
ihre eigene militär präsenz in mali in
frage stellt veranlasst die deutsche
verteidigungsministerium 15 05 zu einem
tweet
sollte sich die zusammenarbeit von mali
mit russischen söldner gruppen
bestätigen stellt das die grundlagen des
mandats der bundeswehr für - ma und em
in frage und gemeinsam mit dem bundestag
müssten wir konsequenzen ziehen
die malische militär unter räumt
gespräche mit russischen sollten an ein
russland dementiert das auswärtige amt
zeigt sich besorgt über die
entwicklungen ich kann fürs auswärtige
amt sagen dass wir kenntnis über
russische gespräche mit der malischen
regierung haben und auch die jüngsten
medienmeldungen über mögliche bilaterale
militärkooperation zur kenntnis genommen
haben wir befinden uns zu diesem ganzen
themenkomplex im austausch mit unseren
europäischen partnern dass die
verteidigungsministerin die grundlagen
des bundeswehrmandats heute kurzerhand
per twitter-nachricht infrage stellt
empört die opposition ein einsatz in
frage zu stellen auf diese art und weise
ist ein no-go wir fordern eine
evaluierung eine exit-strategie ja aber
die sind eine parlamentsarmee das heißt
es muss im bundestag es muss mit dem
auswärtigen amt gesprochen werden weiß
die kanzlerin davon also ich finde es
sehr unseriös zehn tage vor einer
bundestagswahl wirklich weltpolitik
einfach mal überein spät hinaus zu
schicken in deutschland platz die
debatte über das mali mandat nun mitten
in den wahlkampf
und manager nach dem afghanistan abzug
steht jetzt also der nächste bundeswehr
einsatz in frage warum was ist die
kritik an dieser russischen
söldnertruppe die in mali zum einsatz
kommen könnte es sind zwei dinge die man
dazu sagen muss zum einen ist die
situation so wie jetzt ist eine die
sofort den vergleich zu afghanistan
aufkommen lässt zu dem unrühmlichen
abzugeben da erlebt haben denn die
deutsche bundeswehr befindet sich in
mali in einem internationalen einsatz
dieser einsatz wird hauptsächlich durch
die franzosen abgesichert dass die
franzosen jetzt tatsächlich laut über
einen abzug nachdenken das sorgt hier in
berlin für große sorge dass sich ein
debakel wie in afghanistan wiederholen
könnte wenn es auch wieder zu
überstürzten abzug abzugs gedanken
kommen könnte allerdings ist eben der
anlass die gespräche mit einer
russischen söldnergruppe tatsächlich
ernst zu nehmen es geht darum die
sogenannte wagner gruppe eine höchst
undurchsichtige militär gruppe 1 mit
sogenannter privater militärdienst dem
aber nachgesagt wird sehr enge
verbindungen zum russischen militär und
geheimdienst zu haben und von dem man
annimmt dass er ein verlängerter arm des
kreml ist in konfliktgebieten russland
nicht offen auftreten möchte diese
gruppe hat eine sehr unruhen eine sehr
unrühmliche geschichte
die von der ukraine über syrien und
libyen bis tief nach afrika einreicht
die vereinten nationen beschuldigen
mitglieder dieser gruppe zum beispiel
der beteiligung an willkürlichen
tötungen aber auch dem
verschwindenlassen von menschen und
sollte sich die mieten militär unter in
mali tatsächlich einlassen mit dieser
gruppe diese gruppe ins land holen dann
wäre eine neubewertung der lage vor ort
tatsächlich notwendig insofern hat
annegret kramp karrenbauer in der sache
im grundgedanken sicherlich recht ob sie
jetzt in der form die sache richtig
angegangen ist das steht auf einem
anderen blatt danke für diese
einschätzung tag unterlag energie
ein großer wurf soll die jährliche rede
zur lage der europäischen union im
idealfall sein und so spannte
kommissionspräsidentin von allein in den
bogen von der rechtsstaatlichkeit bis
zur corona pandemie als erfolg nannte
sie das inzwischen 70 prozent der
erwachsenen in der eu geimpft sein
schaut man auf die gesamtbevölkerung
sind aktuell knapp 60 prozent
vollständig geimpft das sind nicht ganz
so viele wie in israel aber mehr als in
den usa
anne gellinek über von der leyens
auftritt im europaparlament
es gibt tatsächlich einen
gänsehautmoment bei ursula von der
leyens rede zu europa kurzerhand hatte
kommissionspräsident in die italienische
florettfechterin wbv ins plenum geladen
die gerade bei den paralympics gold
geholt hat die sportlerin ist sowie die
ihnen gern wäre erfolgreich ehrgeizig
ein champion die rede bilanz und
ausblick zugleich die europäische
impfkampagne sieht von der leyen
unerschütterlich als erfolg den
klimaschutz als größte aufgabe die noch
zu bewältigen ist europa soll bis 2050
klimaneutral werden die gesetze dazu
müssen die staats und regierungschefs
allerdings noch beschließen das team wir
müssen jetzt liefern wir können nicht
mehr länger war
draußen vorm parlament halten
abgeordnete der grünen die namen von
menschen und organisationen hoch die ins
visier der polnischen behörden geraten
sind drinnen kritisiert von der leyen
zwar die aushöhlung des rechtsstaats
ohne polen und ungarn aber beim namen zu
nennen trotzdem gibt es in einigen
mitgliedsstaaten besorgniserregende
entwicklung am anfang steht immer der
dialog
aber der dialog ist kein selbstzweck er
muss auch zu einem ziel führen schon
bald werde sie schritte einleiten die
dazu führen dass polen und ungarn
konsequent gelder aus dem eu haushalt
gestrichen werden
wir müssen leider feststellen dass ihr
das in der vergangenheit auch schon oft
gesagt hat aber sie tut es eben nicht zu
vage zu zaghaft kritisieren auch
abgeordnete von liberalen linken und
grünen von der leyen bleibe eine
präsidentin der ankündigung viel
zuckerguss wenig selbstkritik so
zeichnet von der leyen das bild von
europa wirtschaftlich unabhängig ein
vorreiter beim klimaschutz wehrhaft und
selbstbewusst von der leyen sieht sich
als antreiberin aber weiß doch genau
dass sie die staats und regierungschefs
braucht um ihre pläne umzusetzen
durch die pandemie hat deutschland einen
haufen schulden gemacht die frage ist
wie man die abbaut und da gehen die
vorstellung der beiden parteien
auseinander die bei der bundestagswahl
laut umfragen um den ersten platz
kämpfen
die spd ist für steuererhöhungen für
reiche die union gegen steuererhöhungen
mathis feldhoff
diese stimmen sind schon abgegeben hier
in dresden ist die briefwahlen vollem
gange in der sächsischen
landeshauptstadt haben schon
ungewöhnlich hoch 43 prozent gewählt
diese wähler kann man nicht mehr
überzeugen und den rest tobt der kampf
um so heftiger am morgen plädiert die
union noch mal für die komplette
abschaffung des soli und eine
zusätzliche entlastung der mittelschicht
ansonsten machen wir nicht in breitem
umfang steuersenkungsversprechen weil
wir wissen dass die derzeit nicht
finanzierbar sind aber auf jeden fall
keine steuererhöhungen lautet die zusage
der union
eine perspektive die der kandidat der
spd so gar nicht teilt gerade die
pandemie hätte die kassen bis an den
rand strapaziert sagt olaf scholz
deshalb müsse man auch steuererhöhungen
einplanen die pläne der union zur soli
absenkung sein unvernünftig es wird
keinen spielraum geben für steuersenkung
für leute die so viel verdienen wie ein
bundesminister oder noch viel mehr
steuersenkungen machen die 30 milliarden
euro im jahr kosten nachdem wir 400
milliarden euro schulden gemacht haben
um die krise zu bekämpfen und schlicht
und finanzierbar die spd schlägt eine
vermögensabgabe und eine reform der
erbschaftssteuer
unterstützung von potenziellen
koalitionspartner die grünen wollen
einen höheren spitzensteuersatz und
weniger steuervermeidung einkommen ab
100000 euro sollen drei prozentpunkte
mehr bezahlen damit diejenigen die 20 30
40.000 euro verdient steuerlich
entlastet werden können noch elf tage
bleiben zum überzeugen denn trotz hohe
briefwahlbeteiligung gibt es weiter eine
hohe zahl von unentschiedenen
schon jetzt hat der bundestag so viele
abgeordnete wie nie und es könnte nach
dieser wahl noch mehr werden dabei
gelten vorgaben in deutschland gibt es
299 wahlkreise wer dort die meisten
erststimmen bekommt hat einen platz im
bundestag sicher das sind 299
abgeordnete
weitere sitze und die machtverhältnisse
ergeben sich durch die zweitstimmen
macht 598 eigentlich denn seit 2002 kam
von wahl zu wahl immer mehr
kandidatinnen und kandidaten über
ausgleichsmandaten im bundestag folge
ein parlament xxl russlands geht es
könnte bald noch enger im bundestag
werden frei nach der devise
sitzplätze verdichten vor knapp vier
jahren kletterte die zahl der
abgeordneten bereits auf
709 dieses mal droht ein neuer rekord je
nachdem wie die wahl ausgeht ist zu
befürchten dass der bundestag bis zu
1000 mitglieder fassen kann das ist eine
komponente die wir überhaupt nicht
berechnen können der bundes tag platzt
bereits aus allen nähten prophylaktisch
wird tüchtig gebaut mehr als 400 holz
module in stahl gefasst hauptursache der
eigentliche grund ist dass die parteien
heute in den wahlkreisen mit immer
geringeren mehrheiten direktmandate
gewinnen die dann durch ihr
zweitstimmenergebnis nicht mehr gedeckt
sind so entstehen überhang und
ausgleichsmandaten beispiel eine partei
holt mit der erststimme sieben
direktmandate schneidet aber mit der
zweitstimme prozentual schlechter ab
käme deshalb nur auf fünf abgeordnete in
den bundestag würden trotzdem sieben
entsendet macht zwei überhangmandate die
ausgeglichen werden müssen mit den
anderen parteien meiner meinung nach
brauchen wir eine sehr grundlegende
wahlrechtsreform das alte system das für
andere politische zustände konzipiert
war ist an seine leistungsgrenzen
gekommen
aufgebläht und schwerfällig der
politische betrieb zu kostspielig und
schwer vermittelbar
das bundeskabinett hat heute zwei
entscheidungen zugestimmt die viele
betreffen zum einen werden die hartz 4
sätze zum jahreswechsel leicht erhöht
der regelsatz für erwachsene steigt um
drei euro auf dann 4 149 euro zum
anderen soll es weiterhin leichter
kurzarbeitergeld geben können wegen der
anhaltenden pandemie blicken wir da auf
die aktuelle entwicklung bei den corona
zahlen das robert koch institut meldet
12 1455 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind 1110 weniger als vor einer
woche die sieben tage incidents geht den
siebten tag in folge leicht zurück auf
nun 77,9 allerdings seit gestern mussten
628 weitere krone infizierte ins
krankenhaus damit steigt die
hospitalisierung rate auf 1,88
der deutsche gewerkschaftsbund und die
dienstleistungsgewerkschaft verdi
kritisieren dass mehrere bundesländer
planen ungeimpften die sich gegen korona
hätten lassen können keine entschädigung
mehr für verdienstausfälle zu zahlen
wenn sie in quarantäne müssen das sei
eine impfpflicht durch die hintertür so
die gewerkschaften man müsse für impfung
werben statt den druck auf ungeimpfte
immer weiter zu erhöhen
eine wirtschafts nachricht aus china die
auch die deutsche industrie und
finanzwelt verunsichert die krise beim
immobilienkonzern ever grant zieht
weitere kreise staatliche stellen waren
banken laut medienberichten vor zins
ausfällen der immobilienriese droht
wegen einer milliarden verschuldung
zusammenzubrechen das könnte nicht nur
die banken in probleme bringen sondern
auch hausbauer und viele kleinanleger in
den letzten tagen gab es bereits wütende
proteste
alles begann mit einem fischkutter und
protesten gegen atomtests vor alaska
heute 50 jahre später ist greenpeace
eine der bekanntesten
umweltschutzorganisation überhaupt die
spektakulären aktion ihrer aktivistinnen
werde der öffentlichkeit oft bewundert
bei regierungen konzern aber gefürchtet
eine ihre größten erfolge
1995 stemmen sich erfolgreich gegen die
versenkung der shell bohrinsel grand spa
im atlantik unter krueger über 50 jahre
queen ps
amsterdam die rainbow warrior keine
feier nur eine führung exklusiv für
spender der kontrast ist groß zu diesem
kutter ein wort 1971 keine profis
sondern hippies
am anfang von greenpeace waren eine
handvoll aussteiger die dachte man muss
man etwas machen gegen das atomare
wettrüsten dass das ein medienereignis
wurde das packt diese männer tatsächlich
erst als sie zurückkommen fernsehen
braucht bilder greenpeace liefert der
erste bericht im zdf ein bisschen ist
schon dabei umweltschutz und happening
im hafen später geht es gegen
atomtransporte
gentechnik und pardon diese schweine
immer provokant meist illegal oft
lebensgefährlich
150 jahre lang am laufen gehalten dieser
glaube dass ein einzelner mit mutigen
taten etwas verändern kann
der mut sorgt auch mal für kopfschütteln
oder für empörung dieser absturz bei
einem em spiel produzierte die falschen
bilder und für die richtigen vielen
angriffsflächen ölplattformen werden
heute recycelt ölkonzerne bezwingt
greenpeace jüngst vor gericht nicht im
schlauchboot an bord dabei meinen sie
auch nach 50 jahren brauche es beide
anwälte und aktivisten
und noch eine meldung in eigener sache
die zdf korrespondentin katrin eigendorf
erhält den renommierten hanns joachim
friedrichs preis sie sei eine tragende
säule öffentlich-rechtliche
krisenberichterstattung so die
begründung der jury katrin eigendorf ist
seit jahren in brennpunkten die
afghanistan im einsatz
ausgabe berichtet sie auch jetzt nach
der übernahme der taliban von den sorgen
und dem leid viele afghaninnen und
afghanen im heute journal sehen sie
heute ein interview von ihrem e taliban
sprecher mudschahid
und wir kommen zur champions league
werden da sind die deutschen klubs sehr
gut gestartet das kann man so sagen ja
der vfl wolfsburg erkämpfte sich in
unterzahl einen auswärtspunkt beim osc
lille bayern münchen glänzte sogar gegen
einen überforderten fc barcelona
überzeugte der deutsche meister mit
einem deutlichen 13 0 sieg ein abend der
die tristesse um den einst so stolzen fc
barcelona offenbar kein messi keine
magischen momente der deutsche
rekordmeister weist die katalanen in
ihre schranken thomas müller stellt die
weichen mit seinem insgesamt siebten tor
im sechsten spiel gegen lieblingsgegner
barcelona 40.000 im camp nou sehen
keinen brauchbaren torschuss der eigenen
mannschaft die bayern hingegen mit einer
vielzahl bester möglichkeiten zweimal
veredelt robert lewandowski die
pfostentreffer seiner kollegen wir
können am ende noch höher gewinnen auch
in ersten halbzeit höher führen das war
der einzige wermutstropfen aber wir
haben unglaublich stabil verteidigt bafa
dagegen rutscht leicht zu beginn der
königsklassen saison in eine tiefe
sinnkrise
nach dem schwächsten bundesligastart
überhaupt trifft rb leipzig in der
champions league auf den englischen
meister alexander ruda in manchester rb
ist nicht gerade der favorit heute abend
oder
soweit die leipziger nicht gerade vor
selbstbewusstsein strotzen nach drei
niederlagen aus vier bundesliga-spielen
trainer jesse marge sagt er mit blick
auf manchester vielleicht kommen solche
herausforderungen noch zu früh für uns
city mit pep guardiola nimmt nach dem
verlorenen champions-league-finale gegen
sheikh neuen anlauf auf den henkelpott
gegen bundesliga teams gibt es eine
beeindruckende bilanz zuletzt 13 mal
ungeschlagen die letzte niederlage vor
sieben jahren gegen die bayern trainer
der münchner damals pep guardiola vielen
dank alex und die bilder und analysen zu
den spielen in der königsklasse auch zum
auftritt von borussia dortmund bei
besiktas istanbul gibt es dann ab 23 uhr
im sportstudio champions league
unverantwortlich und gefährlich war das
verhalten einiger problemfans beim
regionalliga duell preußen münster gegen
rot weiß essen erst unerlaubte
pyrotechnik auf den tribünen dann
ausschreitungen vor dem stadion 30
personen wurden verletzt es kam zu
mehreren festnahmen
die deutschen volleyballer haben den
einzug ins halbfinale der em deutlich
verpasst gegen italien war die deutsche
auswahl chancenlos und musste sich mit 0
zu 3 sätzen geschlagen geben
da sehen wir noch mal den matchball das
wars von sport in dankeschön sven was
wäre new york ohne den broadway mit
seinen musicals und theater doch wegen
corona herrschte dort eineinhalb jahre
lang still die ist jetzt vorbei volle
säle und begeistertes publikum bei den
ersten aufführungen von gleich vier
großen hit musicals alle mussten geimpft
sein und die zuschauer innen maske
tragen aber das tat der guten stimmung
keinen abbruch
schauen wir auf die lottozahlen die
gewinnzahlen lauten 8 21 27 37 40 41 und
die superzahl ist die fünf weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
und beim wetter ist weiterhin regen
angesagt die details erfahren sie gleich
von ist intelli das heute journal sehen
sie um 21 45 mit marietta slomka auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schön beamte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter heute gab es eine menge regen
ein richtig harter tag liegt hinter uns
das liegt an diesem tief weil das weiter
nach osten gezogen ist aber dessen
kaltfront ist noch bei uns wird im osten
deutschlands und im süden noch für
einiges an regen sorgen denn diese
kaltfront zieht weiter in den süden und
schmiegt sich an die alpenrand und
schauer gibt es außerdem noch von
nordwesten her in der nacht also noch
regen im osten teils mit gewittern
durchsetzt ähnliches programm im süden
ansonsten wird es trockener aber bei
vielen wolken mit temperaturen im westen
bei elf grad und zum beispiel im osten
und 17 grad
morgen dann im norden dann einige
schauer die von nordwesten her rein
ziehen die schauer hier im osten die
gehören zur kaltfront und die drückt
sich richtung alpen und in den
abendstunden kann es hier kräftige
schauer und gewitter geben und dann
schüttet es kräftig bei temperaturen bis
24 grad bevor die kaltfront hier im
süden auftaucht 18 grad ganz im norden
deutschlands und die nächsten tage
werden ruhiger am freitag schauer nach
nordosten hin bis 22 grad und vor allem
der sonntag der wird dann kühler mit 13
bis 20 grad ein schöner abend